For most of human history, ordinary people's
birthdays weren't cause for much celebration.
In fact, in the ancient world if you weren't
among the elite, odds are your birthday would
have mostly just been noted for things like
astrological purposes, rather than throwing
parties in your honor annually.
One of the commonly cited "first" known instances
of something like a birthday being celebrated
appeared in the book of Genesis (40:20-22),
“20 And it came to pass the third day, which
was Pharaoh's birthday, that he made a feast
unto all his servants: and he lifted up the
head of the chief butler and of the chief
baker among his servants.
21 And he restored the chief butler unto his
butlership again; and he gave the cup into
Pharaoh's hand:
22 But he hanged the chief baker: as Joseph
had interpreted to them.”
However, according to Dr. James Hoffmeier
of Trinity Evangelical Divinity School, this
"birthday" party was probably not celebrating
the unnamed pharaoh's literal "birth" day,
but rather his coronation, which marked his
"birth" as a god.
Whatever the case, candles and birthday cakes
as we think of them were not a thing at this
party as far as we know... (probably wouldn’t
have worked out anyway as he had his baker
hanged...)
As for slightly better documented history,
we know from the Greek historian Herodotus
that in the 5th century BCE at least some
Persians celebrated their birthdays, possibly
even eating some form of sweetened cake due
to their practice of eating an "abundance
of dessert"-
“Of all the days in the year, the one which
they celebrate most is their birthday.
It is customary to have the board furnished
on that day with an ampler supply than common.
The richer Persians cause an ox, a horse,
a camel, and an ass to be baked whole and
so served up to them: the poorer classes use
instead the smaller kinds of cattle.
They eat little solid food but abundance of
dessert, which is set on table a few dishes
at a time; this it is which makes them say
that "the Greeks, when they eat, leave off
hungry, having nothing worth mention served
up to them after the meats; whereas, if they
had more put before them, they would not stop
eating."”
As for the Ancient Greeks themselves, while
not connected to a birthday, we do know they
served some form of cake with candles to honor
Artemis, the goddess who, among other things,
had dominion over the Moon.
As such, people offered cakes that were not
only shaped like said celestial object, but
decorated with lit candles, presumably to
make it glow.
It has also been reported that the smoke of
the candles perhaps was thought to help the
goddess hear an individual's prayers as it
ascends to the heavens.
Like the Persians, the Romans (circa 2nd century
BCE – 5th century CE) are known to have
celebrated the birthdays of at least some
"commoners," although it doesn't appear that
the custom was as ubiquitous as it is today.
Rather, when a wealthy person reached a major
milestone like 50, his family and friends
might throw the individual in question a party
and serve a special sweetened cake.
Despite that the Romans had dipped candles
made from tallow going all the way back to
around the 5th century BCE, it does not appear
that they put candles on the birthday cakes,
however.
The Chinese likewise have long had birthday
celebrations, though eating cake on said day
has only been an exceptionally recent phenomenon,
adopted from the Western world.
Instead, in China it is traditional to eat
longevity noodles on one's birthday.
During the Middle Ages in the Western world,
beyond record keeping not exactly being a
priority of the time in this region, it appears
birthdays and birthday cakes were not too
prevalent, in no small part because of early
Catholic dogma that considered birthday celebrations
to be pagan heresy.
Things began to change on this front beginning
around the 12th century, when records of common
births were again being meticulously noted.
As babies were also honored with the name
of a saint to protect them, people began celebrating
their saint's day (as opposed to their own
birthday).
As for re-introducing the birthday cake, this
is seemingly thanks to German bakers starting
around the 15th century.
At this point, they began marketing single-layer
cakes for birthdays, especially for one's
first birthday.
By the end of the 18th century, besides the
Western world again starting to somewhat commonly
celebrate birthdays, the Germans had evolved
their birthday cake a bit, including the very
wealthy sometimes ordering elaborate, frosted
birthday cakes not that different from what
we have today.
Pertinent to the topic at hand, the Germans
were also now putting candles on the birthday
cakes, as seen in their Kinderfeste (children's
festival) birthday parties.
As to who came up with the idea of including
these candles and why they put them there,
this isn't clear, though it is known that
at this point they were adding candles numbering
at least the years the child had been alive
plus often more in the hope of a long life
to come.
Thus, it has been speculated that the impetus
for the candles was to represent the "light
of life."
Other speculative claims state more pagan-like
origins, such as that the candles were there
to protect the child from evil spirits and
that the parties themselves were for grouping
together in hopes of fending off evil spirits,
with the anniversary of one's birth supposedly
making a person more vulnerable to said spirits.
Whatever the case, the idea of putting candles
on birthday cakes seems to have quickly spread
beyond children's birthday parties.
For instance, in 1746 Count Nikolaus Ludwig
von Zinzendorf had "a Cake as large as any
Oven could be found to bake it, and Holes
made in the Cake according to the Years of
the Person’s Age, every one having a Candle
stuck into it, and one in the Middle."
A half century later in 1801, Prince August
of Saxe-Gotha-Altenburg was reported by Johan
Wolfgang von Goethe of having on his 52 birthday
"a generous-size torte with colorful flaming
candles - amounting to some fifty candles
- that began to melt and threatened to burn
down, instead of there being enough room for
candles indicating upcoming years, as is the
case with children's festivities of this kind."
From here this practice of ornate, candled
cakes for one's birthday spread throughout
Europe, presumably initially with the elite
of the continent copying one another and it
filtering down to those who could afford it
from there.
As for the United States, primarily for religious
reasons, celebrating birthdays at all didn't
become widely popular until the early 19th
century.
Notably while Protestants were coming to embrace
the idea of a birthday at this point, Catholics
in the country still largely had religious
issues with celebrating the anniversary of
one's birth.
It should also be reiterated that at this
stage having sweetened cake on one's birthday,
particularly multi-layered, frosted ones as
we often see today, was still something of
an expensive luxury only the affluent could
afford.
It wasn't until the end of the 19th century
that ordinary people had sufficient funds,
and ingredients were cheap enough thanks to
the industrial revolution, that the masses
began incorporating enriched, frosted birthday
cakes as part of a birthday celebration.
When this happened, the idea of a candled
cake and party on one's birthday became nearly
ubiquitous in the Western world, as it is
today, save for some who still abstain from
the practice for religious reasons.
Bonus Facts:
• The music to Happy Birthday to You was
written down in 1893 by Patty and Mildred
J. Hill.
Originally with different lyrics and titled
Good Morning to All, it was sung at the start
of the school day.
Despite that they likely copied the tune from
somewhere else and in turn someone else came
up with the modern lyrics a couple decades
later, up until 2015 the song was copyrighted,
earning a couple million dollars annually
for Warner/Chappell Music who claimed they
held the copyright.
However, finally in 2015 a class action lawsuit
against said company was settled for $14 million
when Warner/Chappell could not show that they
actually held the copyright for the song,
despite that they'd been charging businesses
to use the song to the tune of about $2 million
per year, as mentioned.
It appears from this that the song may now
be in the public domain, though this isn't
quite clear yet, as it's technically possible
another company may come forward to claim
copyright on it, though this is probably unlikely.
Happy Birthday's previous copyright status
is why at certain restaurants they have their
own unique version of the song they sing to
customers on their birthdays.
The dropping of the copyright is also why
these days you’ll occasionally here some
of these restaurants starting to have their
staffs use the classic song instead of one
of their own making.
• Although there are reports of even older
people, the oldest verified person ever was
a French woman, Jeanne Calment, who died on
August 4, 1997 at the age of 122 years, 164
days.
This is possibly around the oldest any human
could live due to telomeres shortening.
In a nutshell, telomeres prevent the strands
of DNA from coming undone and also prevent
them from accidentally fusing with neighboring
chromosomes.
The issue is that these end caps get shorter
each time the cell divides owing to the fact
that the enzymes that duplicate the DNA, with
a little help from short pieces of RNA, cannot
do so all the way to the end of a chromosome.
So something gets cut off every time a replication
occurs.
Telomeres ensure that what is cutoff isn’t
critical information.
But the result of this shortening each time
is that telomeres eventually become too short
to provide an adequate buffer.
For reference, human cells can only be replicated
around forty to seventy times before the telomeres
become too short.
This leads to the cell no longer being able
to correctly replicate and to cell death.
So if you took every cell in your body at
the time you were born and accounted for all
the cells they would produce and so on, multiplied
that number by the average time it takes for
those cells to die, you get what is known
as the ultimate Hayflick limit- the maximum
number of years humans can theoretically live.
That would be around 120 years, give or take!
(You can learn much, much more about this
in our video: Can Lobsters Really Not Die
of Old Age?)